FEMALE SPEAKER: Please join
me in welcoming Bill Belew.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL BELEW: I didn't
do anything yet,
so I wouldn't clap
until I was finished.
So I am going to do something
that, as far as I know,
has never been done before.
And I'm going to
do it just for you.
Now the reason I say that is,
about five, six weeks ago,
I came to this room-- the
tour brought me up here--
I stood here, and I looked,
and I closed my eyes.
And during the time I was
preparing for this talk--
many times-- I
closed my eyes, and I
tried to imagine who
would be sitting here.
And it was you.
I am not bringing
something else and hoping
that you will be interested.
I am bringing something
for you and hoping
that other people
may be interested.
And if they are
not, that's OK, too.
This talk is for you.
Now, the reason I
say, as far as I know,
nobody's ever done this before,
is I'm almost 60 years old.
Three months from now,
I'll be 60 years old.
And I'm a churchgoer.
So in 60 years, I've been
to church almost every week,
probably every week,
more than once a week.
So 60 times 50, that's
about 3,000, maybe 4,000.
Without exaggerating, I have
heard maybe 5,000 talks.
I have probably
given 2,000 talks.
I go to conferences
the same as you do,
and I hear these
talks all of the time.
And so I am pretty sure,
somewhere between 7,000
and 10,000 talks I
have heard or given,
and nobody has ever done
what I'm going to do today.
We hope it will work, right?
So the idea for what
I'm going to do today
came from my children.
My oldest son is a piano player.
And I think he's very good.
But then, all parents will
think their kids are good.
Well, he writes
these piano pieces.
And if you listen to
them very carefully,
you will hear that there are
two songs going on out of sync.
They are not matching together.
So we hear two songs going--
one here, one there-- right?
So it's called counterpoint.
So you would play
a song, and then
there's another song, that,
ha, I can hear that, too.
Well, and then my other
son is a scientist.
And he's a biologist,
a bioscientist.
So he knows how wonderfully
the body will work together.
Now, my right hand doesn't know
what my left hand is doing.
Sometimes, I can write
and listen and tap my foot
while listening to
music at the same time.
They're all not together, but
they all work together, right?
And then, I have a six-year-old.
And you say, what
is a 60-year-old man
doing with a six-year-old?
Well, that's none
of your business.
But I do have a six-year-old.
How many of you have
seen the movie "Frozen?"
Where have you been? "Frozen,"
let it go, let it go, right?
Well, Anna is singing
one song, and Elsa
is singing another song.
And you can hear
them going, depending
on which side you
listen out of, right?
So there are two things always
going on at the same time.
But they match more or less.
So I'm going to try.
No, I'm not going to try.
I'm going to give you two
talks at the same time.
Hm.
One of them is going
to be on the slides.
Just watch the slides.
The other one is going
to be what I say.
They're not going
to be the same.
But they will be
somewhat the same.
But they're not
going to be the same.
So if your thing is watching and
not listening, then just watch.
There will be 15 points, that
if you do only those 15 points,
you will be able to communicate.
You will be able
to talk to anybody
from any country in the world.
Just do those 15.
And they should be pretty
easy to understand just
by looking at them.
And if you want to be
really, really good,
do more than those 15.
So just pick one.
Just do that.
If you just do
that, oh, you will
be able to talk
across any country.
And if you do two of them,
you'll be really good.
And if you do three of them,
you'll be really, really good.
And what if you do 15?
You'll be really, really,
really, really, really, really,
really, really,
really, really good.
I think that was 15.
I'm not quite sure.
So just watch the 15.
Write those down.
Go home, and master those.
Make that what you want to do.
And no matter what
culture you go to,
they will understand
what you are saying.
Now, if watching's not your
thing but listening is,
I'm going to tell
you three stories.
I will tell you three stories.
Do you know, the
number one reason
why people are bad speakers?
There's one reason that's bigger
than all of the other reasons
put together.
There's one reason why
people are very bad speakers.
And I know this, because
I have interviewed--
I have talked to
people-- from China.
I've talked to
people from Korea.
I've talked to people
from Indonesia.
from South America.
I have talked to people
from, I don't know how many,
different countries.
And I ask them this question,
and I get the same answer.
So they come to me.
I what to learn English, Bill.
OK, that works for me.
So if you could speak
English, and you understood
and, well, could speak it
perfectly, what would you say?
Yeah, you see, there's
the point there.
I have asked 1,000 people.
I have asked 2,000 people.
If you could speak my language
perfectly, what would you say?
And they say, nothing.
Because they don't have
what it is they want to say.
You see, if you don't
know what you want to say,
you're not going to
be able to say it.
If you have something
you want to say,
you will find a way to say it.
It always works that way.
Now, I have come up with three
steps, three different steps--
I will call them
levels, but we'll
call them steps--
three different steps.
There are things that
people want to say.
people need to say.
And then there are things
that people have to say.
They are different.
The things that
people want to say
will live on the tip, on
the end, of their tongue.
The things that
people need to say
will dig inside their
belly [GROWLING].
And then the things
that people have
to say, they will
burn in their bones.
It's different.
So I'm going to tell
you three stories.
So we'll go through.
Watch the slides, or
listen, or try to do both.
You guys are smart.
You should be able
to do that, right?
Is anybody here besides me?
Yeah, you can do that.
So I was in Bangkok.
And there was a room.
There were probably
not more than 20 people
in the room at the same time.
And in those 20 people,
12 or 14 of them all
came from a different country.
And they were sitting there.
They're talking in English,
back and forth, back and forth.
They are talking to each other.
And they were saying, we
have written something,
but nobody will read it.
We have written this paper.
We have written this story.
But we can't get anybody
to read the story for us.
What are we going to do?
So their solution, their
answer to that problem,
was let's just share with
each other and pass it around.
And then, hopefully, people
will pay us to do that.
Well, good luck with that.
Let me know how that works.
And so they complained.
They argued so much.
I have this material.
I don't know what to do with it.
I could not take it anymore.
I said, don't you people
know about Google?
So you don't know what you do.
But I know how it plays
out on the other side.
So I said, don't you
know about Google?
Google has made it
possible-- seriously,
I'm running around the world
telling about you guys.
Thank you very much for what
you do-- if you write something
good, you can put
that on the internet,
on this magic
whatever, and people
will find it and read it.
And they thought, wow, I cannot
give stuff away for free.
Are you crazy?
Why would I give
it away for free?
I cannot give something
good away for free.
How will I make
money doing that?
I know the answer to
that question, you see.
And so I now travel the
world telling people
how to use what it
is you have made.
Thank you very much.
You have given me a job.
Well, a year after that,
I went to Kuala Lumpur.
And there were the
same kind of people,
or some of the same
people, but there
were other people in there.
And they were mad.
And they hate you.
Google has stolen
all of my stuff.
And now they have put it
where anybody can read it
and nobody will give it to me.
Nobody will pay me for anything.
You are a thief.
Shame on you.
Did you steal from these people?
Say no.
Of course, I'd say no.
Maybe you did.
Maybe I've caught them.
So you see.
And now they're mad.
You have stolen
all of this stuff,
and you are giving
it away to everybody.
And we cannot make
any money for that.
Well, see, this is
what I get to do.
I said, no, that's
not how it works.
Let me tell you how you
can write very good stuff,
and you can put that
in a place where people
can use their computers
to find you and read you.
And if you're good, you
will make money at that.
Well, isn't that interesting?
So and the process of
doing all of these things,
I have learned a
simple step-by-step,
that if I do these five things,
I can beat anybody at anything.
So how do you do that?
And I thank you for the lessons,
because you taught me this.
It starts with telling stories.
I tell stories.
You have a problem.
You don't know how
to fix that problem.
I know how.
And I fix the problem for you.
And the more I tell
the story about how
I can fix your problem,
the bigger, the better,
the stronger the hero I am.
What's your problem?
Let me solve that problem.
Let me fix that problem for you.
And when I fix it, I
will be your champion.
I will be your hero.
Well, that's the basics.
I tell stories.
And if I tell that
story more than anybody
else who tells the same kind
of story, I can beat them.
So if I tell a story,
and I tell it more,
and then I have
to tell it better.
You see, you guys are tricky.
You see, you cannot
just throw up junk.
You can not throw trash.
You have to give something
good before people
will search and
find something good.
So I have to tell it better.
I tell stories.
I tell more.
I tell it better.
And I tell it more often.
And if I tell that story more
often, I will beat anybody.
And then there's one more step.
You see, people get tired.
Do you ever get tired?
Yeah.
Are you tired?
Yeah, we get tired.
Everybody gets tired.
Well, when I'm in
my workspace, there
are other people trying
to do the same thing I do.
And I know that they get
tired, because I get tired,
and everybody gets tired.
So when the person you are
trying to beat gets tired,
don't get tired.
And you will beat them.
Tell good stories.
Solve real problems,
for real people,
in the real world, in the real
locations that get the real end
result.
Tell it a lot.
Tell it better.
Tell it often.
And tell it longer.
And you can beat
anybody at anything.
So thank you for the job.
Thank you for giving
me something to do.
Oops, lost my screen.
Thank you for giving
me employment.
So if you cannot tell people,
well, we can always show them,
right?
Now, if I just show
them, they will
be able to see what it
is we're going to do.
And I keep telling that story.
Now, the bottom
line here is, when
you are people's
hero, they like you,
because I can fix what is wrong.
So people are terribly-- what's
the word-- they don't quite
get it.
They think if I sit
in a room and create,
if I make something really
well, all of the world
will come to see what I made.
Well, let me know how
that works for you.
You see, there comes that point
where I have made something,
and now I need people
to find that for me.
And that's where you come in.
Well, if you think that you
can do something in your room
and all the world will come
and find you, it won't work.
We call that looking at things
with googly eyes, googly eyes.
But what we want to
know-- what I teach people
is how to look at the world
through Google's eyes.
Do you see the difference?
There's googly eyes, and
then there's Google's eyes.
So if I learn how to write
good stuff for real people that
gets real results,
I can be found.
I know that, and I thank
you for letting me do that.
Well, that's something
I want to tell people.
I want to tell people
how to become a hero.
Well, now there are some things
that I need to tell people,
I need to tell people.
I was in Japan.
I lived in Japan
for almost 20 years.
And while I was in Japan,
I went off to Russia
and taught for a while.
I visited China for a while.
I visited Korea for a while.
I visited several
different countries
as a visiting teacher, OK?
Come teach us.
And so I'm in Japan.
And my boys, both of my
boys, are made in Japan.
It says, made in Japan here.
We just don't show
that to people.
My daughter was made in China
but with American parts.
What can I say?
And so my boys were nine
years old and six years old,
and they were going
to a Japanese school.
One day, they came home
from school with tears.
What's wrong?
Well, Poppa, when we
are at school today,
everybody was calling us half.
You are half.
Their Japanese friends were
telling them, you are only half
of what we were doing.
Well, don't you know?
I was prepared for that.
They came home and
said, we are just half.
Well-- so Benjamin
is my oldest son.
Micah is my younger
son-- I said,
let me ask you some questions.
When you go to
Japanese school, do you
understand your
Japanese teacher?
Well--
Do you understand
the comic books?
Do you understand the
books that you read?
Well, yes.
How about when you watch
Japanese on the TV?
Can you follow?
Yes, I can do that.
Now, do you like Japanese food?
Well, sure we do.
Sure we do.
And what about Grandma?
Can you talk to
Grandma in Japanese?
Well, of course, I can.
I said, what about
when you go to America?
When you go to America,
can you do those things?
Do you eat American food?
Yeah.
Do you like American books?
And do you watch
American television?
Yeah, I like all
of these things.
And can you pay with
American friends?
Yes, yes, I can do
all of those things.
And how about your grandma?
Can you talk to your grandma and
grandpa in America in English?
Well, of course, we can.
Yes, we can.
So now, let's go back to Japan.
And we go back to Japan.
How about your Japanese friends?
Can they eat Japanese food?
Well, yeah.
Can they watch Japanese
television-- yeah-- and so one
and so on.
So what about when your
Japanese friends go to America?
Can they watch
American television?
No.
Can they read English books?
No, they cannot do that.
Can they talk to your
American friends?
No, they can't do that either.
And what about your grandma?
Will they play with
your grandma in English?
No, no, they cannot do
any of those things.
So, I said, Benjamin and
Micah, who is half of whom?
You see, all of their friends
who had been calling them half,
they were the half.
And then, I said, Benjamin
and Micah, I'll tell you what.
You guys are not half anymore.
From now on, you're doubles.
You are doubles.
Well, that was fun.
There was a newsletter.
Remember people who used to
write and put it on paper
and put it in mailboxes
and send it around?
Remember those days?
Maybe some of you don't.
Yeah, there was that.
Well, I was a writer for
one of these newsletters
that traveled throughout Japan.
And so I wrote about
that experience.
I wrote about that
day with my children.
You are not half.
You're doubles.
And it went throughout
all of Japan.
Now, it was not a big group,
but it was the right group.
Because two weeks later
or three weeks later,
in a national newspaper, the
country newspaper, there was,
don't call these
children half anymore.
Let's call them doubles.
And suddenly,
everybody in Japan who
came from two
different countries
were not half of anybody.
They were double everybody else.
And then about two
weeks after that,
we're watching
television, and there's
some singer, [GROWLING],
you know, screaming
and whatever they do.
And the interviewer comes
out--the man he comes out
with-- and he says, how do you
like being a half in Japan?
He said, don't call me half.
Call me double.
And now that word
moves throughout Japan.
And now, it moves its
way into China, as well.
And I know where that word
came from, because I made it.
[LAUGHTER]
BILL BELEW: It was
never said before then.
I had never heard
it said before then.
I never knew anybody who
talked like that before.
I never got the
idea from anybody.
I just sat there waiting for
my children to come home.
I sat there and
waited for my children
to come home and ask me the
question, why do people call me
half?
That's something I
needed to tell them.
That is something I
And it's not the same as I
want to tell them, is it?
It's not the same.
So there is another step.
And this one is things
that I have to say.
Well, what could that be?
I was in Russia.
I was teaching a class.
This was during the Cold War.
It was still 1989.
And I'm teaching a class.
There are probably this many
people in the classroom.
They asked me to come teach
them how to teach English.
They were Russians.
They were very, very good.
Some of them spoke
English better than I did.
Well, and here I am
teaching this class.
And a man in a black suit
comes in with a little girl
and yellow hair.
It looked like
Boris and Natasha.
I don't know if you knew it
from Maxwell Smart, right?
He was a KGB agent.
He was a secret policeman.
And I know that, because
everybody in the room
began to whisper,
[WHISPERING] KGB, KGB.
And when everybody in the room
whispers [WHISPERING] KGB, KGB,
I can hear them, right?
Try that.
Everybody, try it.
[WHISPERING] KGB.
Yeah, you see, we can hear that.
And so after I
taught to that class,
the KGB man came up to
me with his little girl.
He said, Bill, Bill, I want to
take you out to meet a witch.
Well, I've never
met a KGB agent.
And now I get to
meet a witch, also.
And they put me in a car.
And they drove me out
into the darkness.
Have you ever seen the movie
"White Nights," "White Nights?"
Now, I see a head.
If you have not seen
the movie, go home,
watch the movie, "White Nights."
Baryshnikov, the
ballet dancer, right?
He escapes from Russia.
He runs away from
Russia-- the word defect--
he runs away from Russia.
And Gregory Hines goes
the other way, to Russia.
Well, at the end of the
movie, Gregory Hines-- he's
a tap dancer-- he's
in a black sedan.
He's In a black car, and
they're driving him out.
And you think, he is dead.
They are going to kill him.
That's what happened to me.
I'm in a black car,
it's very, very dark,
and they're taking me out
and into the darkness.
Oh, I'm going to die.
I was sure I was going to die.
And the only thing
I could think of,
I hope I meet the
witch before I die.
[LAUGHTER]
BILL BELEW: Otherwise,
why am I doing this?
Well, when I met
the witch, we had
this talk going back and forth.
And the questions she asked
me were the same questions
I was asked just
two weeks before.
I was in Moscow.
Moscow was the only
Russian word I know.
And that's not even said Moscow.
It's Moskova, right?
So I'm in Russia.
I'm in Red Square,
right in the very heart.
There's a big red wall
and a big yellow building
on the other side.
There's dead Lenin, [MOANING].
He's dead right there.
And on the other
side of the wall,
there is a school called
the Moscow Higher Party
School of Communism,
School of Communism.
And never, never had an American
been inside that school before.
They invited me.
Well, that's cool.
I get to go inside the Moscow
High Party School of Communism.
Well, they couldn't
just let me go.
So they had to change my name
from William to Uil'yam, from
Belew to Beloff.
And then the middle
name was Ivanovich.
It should have
been Leonardovich.
So I'm Uil'yam Ivanovich Beloff.
And they took me in there
and said, [RUSSIAN],
and I just go on in.
And they took me to a room where
I met a professor whose job it
was to tell the world
what is communism.
He had his fingers in the
entire world of communism,
and I was invited
to talk to him.
Well, the first day, we
were talking and talking.
And he just comes after me.
I'm just an English teacher.
Help, help!
And he wants to
know, what's better?
Is it feudalism, where
people rule people?
Is it imperialism, where
countries rule others?
Is it nationalism, where
countries rule countries?
Is it capitalism, where
money controls everything?
Or is it Marxism,
this big idea where
everything is going to be OK.
Or is it communism, where
we will decide what is good,
and you will like it?
So he wants to decide which
of these systems are the best.
I don't even know what
he's talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
BILL BELEW: But we
spent a good five hours
going back and forth,
back and forth,
talking about these
different ideas.
Well, I went back
home that night
feeling pretty sad about life,
because he's smarter than me,
right?
He knows things I don't know.
He said, can you come
back again the next day?
And he did.
He said, Bill, come back.
So I went back to
the very same room.
And I come to find out that this
is most likely the very room
where Lenin and Stalin and
these guys got together and sat
and decided this is how
communism should play out.
I'm in the very same room.
And he looks at me
and says, Bill, it's
your turn to decide
what we will talk about.
Ha, ha ha.
Well, I have the
man who can touch
the entire communist
world sitting before me.
And he says, what do
you want to talk about?
Well, now, if you were
asked that question, you
were asked that question in that
situation, what would you say?
What are you going to say?
Well, this is how you do
coding-- over at Google,
we have-- no.
What are you going to say?
Well, I was ready for this.
I was ready for this.
Because I have something
that burns in my bones
that I have to share.
So he is looking at me.
He is sitting
there very quietly.
And it's my turn
to say something.
And this is the first
time I have ever
started a fight that I
was prepared to lose.
You see, this is the first
time I started a fight
that I was prepared to lose.
So I said, OK, let's
talk about God.
OK, he says, how do
know there is a god?
And I began to talk.
And I talked for
some 45 minutes.
And I went through
this reasoning,
and I went through this.
I just kept on going.
45 minutes later,
he said nothing.
So I continued to talk.
And not only is there a god,
this god has written a book.
And that book is
now ours to read.
And he says, how do you
know this book is from God?
Well, I got into
the middle of that,
and I talked for another
45 minutes, maybe an hour.
It's going, you know.
This is how I know
these things to be true.
And when I got done,
he said nothing.
So I continued to talk.
Yeah.
And don't you know
that this God,
who made the world--
and I'm wondering,
why doesn't he fight back--
this God who has made the world,
he has given us a book so
that we can know who that is.
He has also come
to us in a person.
He became a person.
Who is that person, he said.
And I told him who
that person was.
And how do you know
this person, Jesus?
How do you know?
How do you know these things?
And so I went into
history, and I
talked for another 45 minutes.
I did this beyond what we
are talking about here.
But let me give you an example.
In his office, there
was a calendar.
It was a calendar.
And so I said, so do
you see the calendar?
He said, yeah, I
see the calendar.
I said, you know, a year is
once around the sun, right?
A month, it's the moon.
And once around the
moon takes a lap.
A day is when the Earth spins.
What are we to
understand about a week?
How did a week come to be?
Well, that's interesting.
You can look that one up.
And then, I looked at
the calendar again.
And I said, this
says 1989, 1989.
What happened 1,989 years ago?
Why do we go from here to
zero and then back to 1989?
What is in the middle?
Well, I don't know.
I said, you need to
go find that out.
Well, I told him, because
it was my turn to talk.
And then, I'm looking
at the same calendar.
And I said, look,
there is Sunday.
Sunday is in red.
Why is Sunday in red?
Well, I learned some Russian.
You know, there is Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday, Saturday, Sunday,
right, Monday through Sunday,
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN.].
And then, Sunday is [RUSSIAN].
And I asked him.
I said, Mr. Professor, what
does the word [RUSSIAN] mean?
It means resurrection.
Well, isn't that interesting?
For thousands of years
or hundreds of years,
they've been Sunday
Resurrection Day.
And then he began to get it,
you see. [WHISPERING] Ah.
And then I finally
finished talking.
And I looked at him, and I
said, what do you have to say?
Because, I said, it's
his turn to fight.
And he could have
fought, you know.
He put his head down.
I said, what do you have to say?
He looks back, and the words
he uses are [SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
It sounds like interesting.
Very interesting, he says.
Now, I said, I know
it's very interesting,
but what do you have to say?
He said nothing.
What's wrong here?
Tell me something.
Fight back.
Tell me where I'm wrong.
Show me where it's wrong.
And we went home friends.
Well, not two weeks after
that, barely two weeks
after I sat in the office with
him, the Berlin Wall came down.
They did.
Just two weeks after that is
when that all began to happen.
Now, I probably didn't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
BILL BELEW: But you can tell it.
You can blame me if you want to.
You can say, Bill did that.
Bill did that.
Yeah, ah, it was great.
You see, when I am able to talk
to people of other countries,
you see, I can touch people
in their business life.
I can touch my children
and see their lives change.
And if I'm really good,
I can touch the world,
if I just touch
the right people.
Well, I want to know what
it is you want to say.
So some of you are watching
this on the streaming.
Hey!
Some of you will
watch this later.
Some of you are sitting here.
Well, I want to know what
do you want to tell people.
Write that down.
Send it to me.
Put it in the comments.
What do you need to tell people?
Tell me what that is.
What do you you
have to tell people?
When you find the answer
to those three questions,
you will find a way to be able
to communicate to more people.
You will find a way to talk
to more and more people.
Let's see, what did I forget?
Ah, the witch--
yeah-- and the gun.
They had a gun.
I'm sitting in this car on my
way out to meet this witch.
And they said, Bill, there is
something we did not tell you.
So, OK.
He said, there are some
black magic people,
and those black magic
people have a gun.
And with this gun, they can
shoot-- [HUMMING]-- waves.
And if it hits you, they
will control how you think.
And I'm thinking,
if it is not me,
I will not believe
what they are saying.
But I am in the car,
and they are telling me,
they can shoot you
with the gun, and they
can control how
you are thinking.
So I'm sitting in the back seat.
Sergei is here, and
Boris is over there.
I said, Sergei, ask Boris
if he's pulling my leg.
Sergei says, huh?
I said, ask Boris if
he's pulling my leg.
Sergei said, what, what?
I said, pulling my leg.
Bill, how can he pull your leg?
You are sitting here.
He is sitting there.
No, is he kidding me?
Is he joking?
No, no, no.
We have this gun, and
we can shoot people.
And I'm thinking, shoot me.
I know.
I'm telling them,
shoot me with the gun.
I am not afraid.
I do not think so deeply.
So what can happen?
Shoot me with the gun.
Well, we met those people.
They never shot me with the gun.
But we ended up at
the witch's house.
We ended up at
And, you know, she was kind
of short, kind of round,
looked like a fire plug, you
know, for fighting fires.
[LAUGHTER]
BILL BELEW: And
she looked at me,
and she says, Bill,
I want you to help
me fight the black magic.
Will you help me?
Well, that's another
story on another day
that I would like
to tell you about.
But this goes,
again, beyond this.
But she asked me
three questions.
How do know God made the world?
How do you know he talked
to us through this book?
And how do you know
he became a person?
And I know the answers
to those questions.
But what I'm looking
for here is how
to tell these
stories that I want
to tell, how to tell these
stories that I need to tell,
how to tell these
stories that I have
to tell with as few
words as possible.
And if I did my job correctly,
I have used only 800 words
in this whole talk.
And if I stepped outside
of those 800 words,
I was able to explain the words.
You see, there's 800 words.
With 800 words, I can
touch people's lives.
change my children's lives.
And with 800 words, I
can change the world.
If you could change
the world, why
would you not change the world?
Thomas Edison said
about Henry Ford--
we cannot be sure whether what
Henry Ford did was good or bad.
But Henry Ford did not leave
things the way he found them.
Yeah.
If you could change
the world, why
would you not change the world?
And all you need to
change that world
are those 800 words, 800 words.
This is what we call
them the wow factor.
I can touch the world.
So we know the 1-800, right,
the 1-800 numbers you call.
Then you can talk to anybody.
Well, with 800 words, I
can now change the world.
So this is my call
to action for you.
What are you going
to do that makes
the world a different
and better place?
How are you going
to change the world?
Thanks for letting me be here.
I appreciate your time.
I appreciate you sharing
your lunch with me.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL BELEW: So how did I
come to have these 800 words?
All right, so this was back
before Google was even anyone.
Well, no actually it was.
It was, like, 1991, was it?
When was Google founded?
'93.
Well, this was
back in '89 or so.
And so I actually did it
a little bit before then.
I was teaching in a university.
I had a bunch of students
who were really stupid.
And they needed
extra work to do.
So I gave them extra work to do.
So what we did was
we watched movies.
We watched 50 different movies.
And in each of those 50 movies,
we wrote out the dialogue
on all of those
50 movies by hand.
And, you know, exactly, we
wrote them out all by hand.
And then each of
the students who
were failing, they didn't know
English, but they could count.
So I said, now, just go through
and circle all of the words.
Circle all of the "the's."
Circle all of the "wents."
Circle all of the "is's."
And let's list them all up.
So I had 50 students over
three years watch 50 movies
and list up all of these words
and most frequently ordered.
There are about 612
words, 612, 613 words.
It depends how you
group them together.
I can talk about
86% of everything
I want to say with 612
words, not 800, 600.
About 7% of all movies
are names, places.
Let's go to Cincinnati.
You know, let's go kill
people in South Africa.
You cannot.
You have to learn them.
And then another 8% percent or
so, I forget the exact numbers.
It's in the book, whatever.
I'm not going to
sell you a book.
But I'll send you the list
if you give me your email.
So another 8% of all words in
a movie is only used one time.
The word pops up, and
it's never used again.
Don't touch that detonator.
You will die.
Well, I don't know what it is,
but if I touch it, I'll die.
So it's something that
dies people or, you know,
kills people.
So we can understand,
that's how we learn words
by using the 800, to be
able to define those things.
So I want to encourage
you to find, you know,
develop, create,
build on those 15.
If you're just an
expert at what you do,
just be really, really
good at what you do.
And people will find
a way to understand.
Oh, that's easy.
And then we build on that.
If I cannot tell or if I
don't master words, well,
I can show people.
That's why I created
a deck and so on.
So add up those 15.
Pick and choose
the ones you like.
Use the ones you
want to use, right?
And add to those 800 words,
and you can change the world.
AUDIENCE: So as engineers, we
often talk in a techie way,
where we have a lot of
words to explain something.
So do you have any suggestions
on how to make our talk,
like, our presentation
more essential?
BILL BELEW: What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: I mean, how to make
our talks or presentations
in a condensed way?
BILL BELEW: Well, see, I can
connect those techie terms.
I can connect to that
techie expertise.
Whatever it is you're trying
to do, all of those words,
all of those ideas,
all of that job,
is connected by these
800 words, right?
So here, I need to do this,
while I need to do that.
And that's where the
show-me tells me.
So if I can show and I can
connect with those 800 words,
I can tell anybody anything.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BILL BELEW: The problem is
we try to overwhelm people
with how smart we are
when we different words.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you travel
a lot, you know, over Asia.
So just compare Asia
culture and here.
Can you put some comment on when
you say deliver some message?
Do we need to be very
culture-sensitive?
BILL BELEW:
Culturally-sensitive,
well, when you go to Asia to
speak to a professional group,
you don't wear shorts.
No, I'm kidding.
Ah.
I think it comes down to,
people are people everywhere.
And what they want
to know is, what
is in your heart that connects
to what's in my heart.
You know, we don't have to
worry about cultural gaps.
We don't have to worry
about cultural gaps.
All I need is to consider what
it is that I have to share,
what it is that I need
to share-- so I'm back
to the very basic, what I want
to, what I need to, what I have
to-- and when people
begin to understand
those different levels, all
of that culture breaks down.
You know, every culture loves
their children, for example.
In every culture, people
want to do a good job.
They want to be experts
at what they do.
And every culture wants to
have that [FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
Everybody wants to be liked.
And those things don't change.
How that plays out is different.
But those elements of
those-- those 15 that I'm
sharing with you-- those are
the same in every culture.
So what I want to do is I
want to pick 1 or 2 or 3,
or all of those 15, and
there are some more.
I want to pick 1, 2,
3, or all of those 15,
and I want to be able to
connect those 15 with 800 words
to anybody.
And I don't have
to be overwhelmed.
I don't have to think
too hard about it.
AUDIENCE: Your other
slides, you mentioned
the use of Google eye,
is Google kind of funny--
BILL BELEW: Look at the
world through Google's eyes.
AUDIENCE: Yes, through eye.
But, like I say,
in China or Russia,
there are some local
or our search engine.
BILL BELEW: Can I use
Baidu Index here with that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah, that's it.
You can talk about it.
So that is the same thing
if you are a person?
BILL BELEW: I'm outside
of my 800 words here.
Is that OK?
So the rules are the same.
You know, we are
looking for people
who can satisfy my problem.
So at the very
basic level, there
is a person who wants
something, but there
is a problem in the way.
And so they are looking for
the fix to that problem.
And they will do
that with the index.
They will do that with Baidu.
They will do that with Dogpile.
They will do that especially
with Google and Bing.
I hope I don't get in trouble.
You see, it's I
have this problem.
Who can solve this
problem for me?
And the more problems I can
solve, the better the expert
I am.
Now see, I don't say, just
throw a bunch of stuff.
No, we don't throw
a bunch of stuff.
We want to solve real
problems, for real people, who
need real answers,
in real locations
so that they can make real
changes to their life.
And then it works the same.
I understand that Baidu's about
three years behind Google.
Ah.
You know, Than.
You tell me.
I don't know.
How many years is Baidu behind?
OK.
You can make up something, and
we won't know the difference.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for me, just I
feel maybe the kind of pretty
much control, right, you
know, a little bit several
censored some information.
So that different.
BILL BELEW: If you want me
to talk about censorship,
I'll just get myself
in trouble, right?
You know, different countries
have different rules.
So we play by the rules of
the different countries.
Now, I don't want to
start a discussion.
That's beyond the scope here.
But, you know, the old
saying, when in Rome.
You know, in Japanese, we
say, [SPEAKING JAPANESE].
It's the same thing.
When you're in
Goa, do like Goans.
So there is a reason why
that proverb has been around
for a very long time.
Because that's how we
should do things, I think.
All right.
Well, thank you very much
for sharing your lunch
time with me.
MALE SPEAKER: And let's
thank the speaker again.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]